36 years old 6-3 215 is sixth
sixth opening day starts
48 strikeouts 12 walks in those starts a
2-1-4 era
so i told you in the open only pitcher
since 1900 to strike out at least 11
batters in consecutive opening day
starts 12 in 2019 against the mets 11
last year
against the yankees and guess what he's
fired up joe looking to get these bats
cracking today see if they can get out
to an early lead against max scherzer
this is his sixth opening day start with
the nationals and he's out there taking
on acuna albies and freeman and the top
of the first inning scherzer is ready
goes into his wind up and now for the
ball game and the first pitch swung on
and lifted high in the air out towards
left field back to the wall this one is
out of here ronald acuna hits a home run
on the first pitch that he sees for max
scherzer lifted high into the heavens
and it's one nothing braves
that didn't take long at all acuna's on
the board and maybe that's gonna break
things open for the braves offense a
leadoff home run for acuna the 20th of
his young big league career look max is
trying to get ahead throws that first
pitch fastball ronald look he's always
ready for to go on that first pitch he
got one up in the zone and ronald lacuna
junior wasted no time going ambush on
the first pitch one-nothing braves
nobody on 2020 nationally mvp freddie
freeman stands in over nine for the year
and he unloads to deep right field that
ball's got a chance that ball's gonna
fly out
long home run for freddie freeman into
the second deck
two solo homers for the braves in the
first inning he got a hanging breaking
ball slider here right in the zone i'll
tell you something i guarantee you
hakuna ozzie freddy is they were sick of
hearing about what happened this weekend
too and they're coming out swinging the
bats
second deck that is a long way away for
freddie freeman his first hit a home run
and at 164 games against the nationals
freddie now with 24 career home runs
and here's drew smiley who's really been
around the last couple of years fourth
team in his last three seasons and the
sixth ball club he spits for in his big
league career yeah 31 years old 6-3 190
braves signed him to a one-year deal
hoping he would be
a nice number five starter if he pitches
any way he did in spring training he's
gonna be real good a three two nine era
16 strikeouts just two walks in 13 and
two third spring training games so
fastball cutter curveball into the pitch
turner takes fastball called strike
three
and turner is out two minutes away first
strikeout for smiley
sedans be one for 10 to start the year
sure a little ambushed in the opening
inning fifth time in 369 career starts
he's allowed two or more homers in the
first inning and now the wind and the
2-2 from scherzer swung on hit in the
air to right center and hit well this is
deep way back going going and gone
goodbye
a third home run for the atlanta braves
in the first two innings that one over
the big 14 foot eight inch wall in right
center landing in section 141
and the ball is flying out of here off
the bat of the atlanta braves
who managed three runs and 12 hits in
three games in philadelphia they have
three hits and three solo home runs
and now the new guy has a chance to be
an early game hero here he must feel
like he landed on a spaceship and put on
just a new uniform doesn't even know
where he is right now 108 career homers
now the set of the pitch oh two swinging
a line drive fair past the third baseman
riley and down the left field line hits
the sidewall and juts out stevenson
rounds third he's going to try and score
relay to the plate is offline by ozuna
heading for third now
and there is luke roy but the throw will
beat him to riley and he is out that
ends the inning but lukroy with a double
down the left field line scores a pair
stevenson running on the arm of ozuna
sent by bobby henley and the throw was a
miserable one scoring two
three two braves here in the top of the
third inning
high fly ball hammered to left center
field lacuna's gonna have another home
run
four solo homers for atlanta a
multi-homer game for acuna and it's only
the third inning mix it up ronald 4-2
your score
there's a little bit of a breeze
blowing out but the ball with the warmer
temperatures
upper 70s it is just flying off the bat
of the braves
turner has been a terror on the braves
in his career listen to these numbers
325 hitter in his career versus the
braves
13 home runs
39 rbis
and 19 doubles goodness gap to left
center in the outfield for turner
batting from the right side he launches
one to left field this is way way back
there ozuna to the track to the wall and
this game's tied
trey turner puts one in the bullpen the
nationals first home run of 2021
ties the game at four and listen to this
crowd that ball was touched folks
got a new ball game 4-4 this would be a
2-2 here it is
swinging a miss he got him on a slider
and max has now retired 10 in a row and
he's got strikeout number nine
max scherzer in his career on opening
day is one and three this is start
number six one no decision looks like he
may have thrown his 91st and final pitch
six innings five hits the four solos
didn't walk anybody struck out nine max
finishes with a flourish retiring the
last 10 breaks they've got to go for the
strikeout here with
the runner at third and the base is
loaded
check swing over the mound they'll have
one play it's the first zimmerman did he
come off the bag and hold it yeah he did
what a play by zimmerman at the first
base bag the braves are going to
challenge that call at first a run's
going to score
that's a heck of a play to get it out
with the speed of
acuna
the braves were thinking about
challenging
how zimmerman corralled the ball at
first whether he had possession of it
but they will not challenge it and it
gives it land of the lead bare-handed
pick up one hop throw and
somali zim got it in the glove and then
in the heel of the glove with the right
hand was just making sure that ball
didn't roll out of the glove he had it
cleanly the whole time aces are loaded
with one out five for atlanta bottom of
the eighth
minter sets the old one to stevenson
swung on hit on the ground off the glove
of the diving riley deflects to the
shortstop swanson throw to second not in
time
as garcia scores and the game is tied
it's the nationals five and the braves
five well here we are in the ninth
inning games on the line all right who
wrote this what more could you ask for
in opening day
he rips it it's up the middle victor
robles comes around third and the
nationals walk off the braves on opening
day and an opening day carly w
is in the box
they're mobbing once soto out there
second base
the nationals come from behind they've
beaten the braves
six to five
unbelievable
soto's first hit of the year
is a walk-off game winner